Colombia camino a la paz total en una
reunión de miembros del futuro gobierno
con organizaciones se habló de una
estrategia de acogimiento y beneficios
penales para los grupos criminales en
lugar de sometimiento eso sí desde la
justicia
es impresentable
ante los propios colombianos el pensar
que puede hacerse procesos de paz en
impunidad el plan del Golfo o
autodefensas gaitanistas de Colombia
Podría tener beneficios judiciales si
aportaciones y rutas de narcotráfico
esto cuando en las últimas semanas han
llevado a cabo un plan de asesinatos de
policías denominado plan pistola matando
al menos 36 uniformados una forma de
mostrar control territorial y unidad de
Cara a la negociación otra posibilidad
de paz conocida el miércoles ha sido con
las disidencias de las FARC pese al
desarme de la que fuera la guerrilla más
grande de América Latina en 2016
antiguos mandos abandonaron el proceso y
se reorganizaron ahora se abren a una
segunda oportunidad para que un acuerdo
queremos un clima propicio para un
acuerdo de exceso al fuego bilateral
pero de la negociación que más se ha
hablado en las últimas semanas es con la
guerrilla del Ln retomando las
conversaciones iniciadas en la Habana
durante el gobierno de Juan Manuel
Santos y rotas en el de Iván Duque Así
ha estado tuiteando su comandante alias
Antonio García importante que haya
expectativas por la paz en Colombia es
la paz el principal objetivo del
gobierno de Gustavo Petro y Francia
Márquez quienes tomarán posesión el 7 de
agosto
[Aplausos]